as we enter the third week of this
conflict General Sir Richard Barons is
with us he's been monitoring what's been
happening on the ground in Ukraine and
we are seeing the Russians slowly
getting closer to Kiev that Convoy that
we saw heading its way towards the
capital is now dispersed so what we've
seen developing over the last 10 days a
Russian Force is closing in on on Kiev
from the Northwest and the Northeast
those forces are getting closer they're
moving off the roads into battle
positions and they're beginning to try
to encircle the city and if we take a
look now at a closer picture of the
capital we're saying this isn't going to
be straightforward is it because coming
into an urban area is always difficult
with fighting particularly somewhere as
big as Kiev so we need to understand
this is a really big fight this is a
much bigger scale of challenge for the
Russians than they've taken on so far
what we'd expect to see is that Russian
forces approaching the city on a number
of axes and as they do that their
armored forces will lead so tanks in the
front and the ukrainians will resist
that as they approach the edge of the
city the Infantry will take charge and
the tanks will follow and it'll all be
supported by massed and very destructive
artillery the ukrainians are ready for
that and the resistance will be very
stiff so breaking into Kev is going to
be a massively difficult fight and this
is where the Spectra of chemical weapons
appears to being raised by Russia
because if the Russian assault stumbles
or is stalled by the ukrainians one way
they may elect to unstick that is by
using chemical weapons against the city
with all the abhorrent effects that
we'll have okay and we've seen some
developments uh Northwest of Kiev uh
Beres Jana where I'm circling now I
think we can show you some satellite
pictures from there which we think show
rocket launchers and that obviously
potentially is very concerning because
this is a place that is only 35 or so
kilometers away from the capital so this
is a very good illustration of the
Russian forces coming off the road and
deploying into battle positions that
looks like a battery of six rocket
launchers in positions where they could
fire and they are now in range of Kia
okay and let's look now at um the whole
of Ukraine what do you think we should
be looking at in particular when it
comes to the south of the country so a
lot of focus on on Kiev right you say
right now but there are at least four
other things we need to look at the
first is the battle for Mario Paul
because if the Russians take that City
they will complete the land bridge from
Russia to Crimea which has clearly been
one of their main objectives and over
the last 24 hours we've seen the first
strikes on denipro that suggests the
Russians are inclined to move further
into Ukraine and maybe close up to the
river wherever they can and then in the
last 24 hours two airstrikes way in the
west of the country on airfields that's
never happened before and that looks
like strikes designed to wear down the
Ukrainian Air Force and finally
the expectation that the Russians will
assault Odessa to complete the isolation
of Ukraine from the Black Sea so these
airstrikes are the first
strikes yes they have from the Russians
thank you so much General Sir Richard
Barons thank you